julie garnier oratrice nationale de la
france insoumise julie garnier merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
jean luc mélenchon l'a annoncé hier le
groupe la france insoumise votera contre
le plan de déconfinement du gouvernement
selon ses mots ça a l'air d'être de la
démocratie c'est seulement de la
brutalité pourquoi ce constat le constat
il est clair vous avez un vote qui en
fait n'en est pas un
vous avez un nez plein débat ce qu'ils
appellent un débat mais qui n'en est pas
un
quand vous arrivez en assemblée que vous
ne pouvez pas amendée que vous pouvez
pas faire de d'amendements que vous
pouvez faire de modifications quand vous
ne pouvez faire rien finalement
eh ben ce n'est pas un débat ce n'est
pas une vraie démocratie c'est un
simulacre et c'est ce que nous
condamnons
pourtant les choses sont importants
enfin nous avons quand même un plan de
déconfinement et c'est important pour le
pays nous nous avons fait des
propositions nous avons à rédiger un
document de 34 pages parce que des
propositions il ya plusieurs il n'y a
pas qu'une seule façon de sortir de la
crise il y en a plusieurs et nous avons
besoin d'écouter tout le monde et de
faire voter les gens et ça
malheureusement ce n'est pas ce qui est
proposé ce qui est proposé c'est un vote
en bloc ou toutes les toutes les mesures
seront prises en une seule fois
que ce soit le tracking que ce soit les
autres mesures et ben ceci n'est pas de
la démocratie
s'il faut écouter s'il faut un débat
alors dans ce cas là il faut y avoir il
faut doit y avoir la possibilité
d'amendés de corriger de rectifier de
supprimer etc
et ce n'est pas le cas alors du ps aux
verts des républicains au rassemblement
national et même des voix 1 chez lrm
nombreux sont ceux qui comme vous vivent
mal ce vote dans l'urgence dans ces
conditions comment est ce que vous allez
aborder à la france insoumise le débat
de demain
comme je vous le disais nous on a fait
déjà une proposition on a écrit un
document de 34 pages où il ya plusieurs
propositions sur quelles sont les
mesures à prendre pour cette crise et
pour en sortir et pour planifier le
déconfinement nous avons donc des
mesures comme des mesures basiques mais
les masques la gratuité des masques que
c'est ma soit diffusée de manière
massive aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il
propose par exemple il m'a non le prix
eh ben il ne sera pas fixée ce sera le
prix du marché et puis débrouillez-vous
or c'est un c'est un produit de première
nécessité
et si c'est un produit de première
nécessité alors il doit être diffusé et
accessible pour tous pas pour
quelques-uns pour tous ensuite nous
avons aussi proposé la planification
économique parce qu'il est vital pour
notre pays d'avoir à sa disposition tous
les moyens économiques pour pouvoir s'en
sortir
je ne prendrai qu'un exemple mais quand
on parle du masque pourquoi est ce que
en 2018
le gouvernement a laissé partir une
société la société honeywell qui a
délocalisé son entreprise de production
de masques en tunisie alors que nous en
avons besoin
et bien tout ça ce sont des propositions
concrètes mais qui nous permettent de
sortir et d'avoir et ben tous les moyens
pour justement protéger la population
des masques des tests etc
aujourd'hui on se pose la question juge
je terminerais là dessus mais on se pose
la question à quelle fonction répondent
le gouvernement quand il prend ses
décisions
je m'interroge ne serait-ce que sur la
réouverture des écoles et je suis en
colère parce que je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ces décisions sont prises
si les parlementaires ne sont pas
consultés si la scientifique sont contre
alors à qui répondent le gouvernement
sur les décisions qu'il comprend
justement sur la question de la
réouverture des écoles le 11 mai quel
est votre regard sur cette date est ce
qu'il faut attendre
est-ce qu'il faut plus de mesures pour
les élèves quelle est votre position sur
cette reprise des écoles je suis maman
de deux enfants et je ne comprends pas
ces décisions et je pense que tous les
parents ne comprennent pas ces décisions
et quand on a un gouvernement qui nous
dit eh bien vous ferez finalement comme
bon vous semble c'est vous qu'il
déciderait si vous les remettre ou pas
eh ben je trouve que c'est mépriser
encore plus la réalité parce que les
parents n'ont pas leur ont pas le choix
ceux qui doivent reprendre le travail
demain n'auront pas d'autre choix que de
laisser leurs enfants et c'est bien pour
ça justement que les écoles rouvrent
pour faire plaisir malheureusement au au
medef au syndicat patronal pourquoi est
ce que les écoles rouvrent alors que les
scientifiques disent qu il n'y a aucune
raison pour qu'elle ouvre le 11 mai il
n'y a aucun principe au rien ne permet
aujourd'hui aux enfants
voir tourner sereinement à l'école et
aux enseignants d'exercer sereinement
rien ne le permet parce que comme je
vous le disais hé ben les masques ne
sont pas là les tests ne sont pas là etc
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
situation qui est préoccupante vous vous
rendez compte
je terminerai juste là dessus mais vous
rendez compte que dans notre pays
actuellement on a des gens qui sont en
famine qui n'arrivent plus à se nourrir
à la france a soumises on avait des
propositions savez dans notre programme
de l'avenir en commun on disait
l'encadrement des prix l'encadrement de
l'alimentaire l'encadrement des loyers
tout ça ce sont des propositions qui
peuvent être prises et qui répondrait
encore plus à la crise d'aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement ne
prend pas ces mesures là pourquoi est ce
que le gouvernement
le prend toujours les mêmes mesures que
pour ceux qui vont profiter de la crise
et c'est ça qui m'inquiète c'est que
dans cette crise au moment où on compte
les morts
eh ben il y aura aussi des profiteurs et
ça c'est scandaleux merci julie garnier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes oratrice
nationale de la france en sont mises